Third Street in Los Angeles a young hip
neighborhood known for trendy shops and
restaurants in 2010 Allen and Jen
saffron opened a restaurant called The
Burger Kitchen good evening welcome to
Burger Kitchen my name is Alan thank you
for coming Ally's always had the dream
to run a restaurant because he's always
enjoyed meat you do the cheese in the
middle you seal the beef and then you do
the cheese on the top that's what the
ultimate cheeseburger is I have really
eaten meat all my life I've eaten in
hundreds of different steak restaurants
and then I figured I'd try and get into
a hamburger restaurant but we didn't
have the money to open up the best
burger in L.A and I took the money from
my son Daniel I was kind of dragged into
this I got a sizable inheritance from my
grandfather there was money in a trust
account and my dad took 250 000 of my
money to put it into this restaurant hey
guys how you doing because of that I had
to make the place work but my dad is not
running Burger Kitchen well all of our
burgers are prime weigu that's the best
meat you can buy in the country I've now
changed our standard Burgers all to
Australian wager it's all Frozen we take
it out of the freezer I mean it sucks
though dude I know it's like really dry
throw that out my God you buy your
patties pre-made and they're dry and you
know it's not good but you continually
say it is because you don't have any
taste buds really not good
Burger Kitchen is managed by a
dysfunctional family we got three Chiefs
and about four Indians today there's a
lot of tension within all the family
members which filters down to us of
course I happen to order a sweet potato
fries and I have two tickets
you need to listen to me it's hard to be
belittled every day and so for me to
come to work now is like almost
unbearable
handles and then you can come back and
actually
you can expedite nothing thank you it is
such a chaotic work environment with
Alan Jen Daniel is he doing a natural
for 45 yes he's doing a natural for 44.
it is just a train wreck and a half I
can organize the tickets I don't know
why they can't get it through their
[ __ ] skulls it's okay all right relax
I did not picture myself doing this but
these are the cards I've been dealt and
I want to make it a success table 11
still does not have their size I it's
coming it's all coming I've told Ricardo
to make on the Fly I know I know I know
I know I know but my father he does not
treat me as an equal partner he still
treats me like a child it's very
infuriating please help me please
I am absolutely at the end of my rope I
don't have anyone to lean on I really
don't Chef Ramsay is our last hope
[Music]
[Applause]
what an amazing place at the restaurant
bang in the middle of Los Angeles a
billion concerned wow
nice hello good morning how are you Alan
Safran how are you Alan good to see you
thank you very much this is my wife Chad
Jen good to see you when Chef Ramsay
arrived and it just blew my mind let's
sit down have a a chat shall we yes I
mean we've got Chef Ramsay in here to
improve us
otherwise what the hell is he here for
nice to meet you both nice to meet you
good to see you
um how long have you been open 16 months
so 16 months ago yeah so it just opened
yes is the business making money no
we're losing 5 000 up to six thousand a
month every month
wow wow
how can it go so wrong I I think it was
a combination of a lot of things that I
think we did wrong I think we changed
the menu many to too many times how many
times we changed the menu probably 10.
10 times yeah that's nearly once a month
what about the chef I mean normally a
menu changer when the chefs change how
many questions
10 as well yeah front of house being as
bad yeah we've been through about 20
service
10 menus 10 chefs 20 servers what's
going on Yelp there's killed us
we also crashed us terribly they're also
deleting five-star reviews oh come on I
can prove it I can show you right on the
hill
is there a plot against you from yell to
close this business no question in my
mind come on you've been watching too
many [ __ ] bomb movies
so
um opening restaurants in La is pretty
expensive where'd the money come from
Alan had about 250 000 that he inherited
from his dad okay nice so he put all
that money into it and then we started
running out of money and in order to
open my husband went to my son and now
my son Daniel is in for another I think
over 250 000 as well because he
inherited some money too I I was
managing his money so I actually took
part of that money and as the manager of
his funds you then invested in the
business yes did your son Daniel know
well of course he knew eventually
[Music]
we say eventually I told him after the
fact what I kind of forced him into it
by taking his money
[Music]
seriously
Daniel here he's in the business he does
the nighttime [ __ ] okay you work in the
daytime and you don't work together uh
not really that much our heads log
together right my son has a great deal
of resentment towards me and I don't
know why
what about the food I think it's pretty
damn good now yes I'd say it's four to
five stars four to five stars so you're
one star out okay but I can't wait to
taste it we've got the background thank
you I appreciate it okay thank you Chef
Ramsay will love my Burgers without a
shadow of a doubt
I'm Marilyn Meredith nice to see you
first off what's wrong with the rest
there's lack of management and burgers
they're never cooked right they're
always sent back wow yeah I tell people
that I'm sorry probably 15 times a night
there's no consistency whatsoever and
that's wearing on me like as a person I
go home and I'm like oh I feel so guilty
for serving bad food okay let's start
off I'm in California so let's go for
California and how would you like it
cooked medium rare please thank you okay
okay gotta see the Australian meat time
yeah obviously I'll have to go for the
award-winning bro okay yeah I think
we're done thank you thank you good to
see you too
dirty Place guys come on
okay this is a lot of food at first I
loved working at Burger Kitchen but all
I'm doing now is flying humans to
management David I'll handle this Jen I
want you to get out of the way right now
it's a runaway restaurant I have no
control 13 said their burgers
yes anything you have to say go through
meetings
Chef David does not like me he doesn't
want me in the kitchen oh my God that
woman
and he tends to gossip and blame me for
a lot that's going on out walks the
Diablo we've made some errors here in
Staffing this is like a green ring
circus Chef Ramsay I noticed you ordered
the cowboy that'll take a little longer
don't you worry it's a one pound burger
lovely executive chef David Blaine yes
got the magician no no he's not the
magician right he's just coincidentally
the same name he was the head pastry
chef at the Peninsula hotel now he's the
executive chef of the burger restaurant
yes David Copperfield you dessert Chef
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you're from here when I came in here
I was I wasn't allowed to do any of my
recipes I had to do exactly without what
I told me to do
that's the California even if I knew it
was wrong I still had to do it this is
the California Burger wow thank you
okay California Burger I better let you
eat yes I'll leave you to it thank you
[Music]
um
Bread's just sweet sweet and doughy
Bland tasteless raw meats no flavor
wow that's nasty how are you doing yeah
into the kitchen cooking the season I'm
um I know they throw a little bit of
salt in well don't see blind because
they're missing you I mean
what's wrong with this one
stop stop stop stop what's wrong with
that one no seasoning he doesn't like it
it's one of the best burgers I've ever
tasted in my life so it's very
disappointing it because it's a natural
natural with white cheddar yes
how was it cooked what do you ask for no
that's good medium rare oh we're good on
it yeah yeah this one is natural with
white cheddar oh this is
yeah great thank you
[Music]
wow
a wolverine Burger
shocking Marilyn silent
[Music]
I can't believe that my burger was that
bad
that is just shocking
I don't know what to think anymore isn't
this natural it's um
oh come on guys what the [ __ ] is that
I was shocked that it was undercooked
because I okayed the burger but you know
we were under a lot of stress David this
is really bad but instead of looking at
their own deficiencies they want to put
it on me I'm about done with Charles
[ __ ] here man
yeah 100 I am their skate building I'm
about to blow up
Jeff Ramsay had a horrendous start to
his lunch
and after sending another raw Burger
back to the kitchen David this is really
bad I'm about to double strong [ __ ] here
man wow I'm out of here
Chef David Blaine wants to disappear I'm
about to blow up
people are crazy I laughed out of
frustration but when I came on I made a
deal with my staff to stay
I keep my word and that's what I'm doing
let's do this okay we got the big Cowboy
Burger medium rare if you don't have any
of those extra fake ones I don't know
who is this
oh this is going to be interesting we
got the Cowboys done I'm terrified to
bring out of this burger I don't even
think he could swallow change your eyes
here is the cowboy Burger
cowboy
with a very small hat on top look at the
bun where'd you start
[Music]
honestly look at that
[Music]
come on seriously
39
you'd expect a decent bump
[Music]
greasy cooked to hell Dad thanks man
that is Dreadful football I'm sorry I
think it's not your fault
wow
I was shocked disappointed embarrassed
heard
Steve prize up guys but one thing I have
that's a little different is an
Australian meat pie the Australian meat
pie is the number one Staple in
Australia I have brought them to America
and Chef Ramsay will absolutely love it
that's Ramses by the way this is not
gonna like it what she's not gonna like
it
so this is the the Australian meat pie
the beef
[Music]
what a mess I mean that is disgusting
that Australian pie can [ __ ] off back to
Australia with pleasure I've got raw
doughy pastry on the top and Soggy gooey
stuff on the bottom one word for this
meow cat food the disgusting didn't like
nothing at all nothing
it's everything I believe Chef David
can't handle the menu he's not an
executive chef as he claims we didn't do
good he's a pastry chef
wow
well that was a eye note let's beat the
team this is uh Chef David this is the
executive chef David how are you David
playing right the magician wow show me
what your magic today this is jalapeno
jalapeno okay great David that was
[ __ ] hideous
everything I've tasted has been nasty
awful Bland and you've watched all that
coming out or did you cook any of it I
helped Club everything and you can't
work your magic on a burger
seriously
you get paid as an executive chef wow
what's funny now is this an ego massage
for you
I follow the recipes as I am told by the
owners and if I try to change the
recipes I am tossed out of here what
not quite sure man up you can drink it
again drinking again my husband doesn't
drink I don't know I don't know I can't
get the truth out of anybody here
explain this to me Jen he does have a
lot of control in the kitchen that's not
true Chef what about the mushrooms and
you change the whole recipe and you
added you didn't want salt on the
mushrooms let's tell the truth did you
add wine to the mushroom recipe that's
how you make saute restaurants I just
asked a question did you add water yes
ma'am you didn't tell anyone that you
added wine to the mushrooms how do you
missing the points you're focusing on a
mushroom mushrooms are important to me
I'm from Poland I think of all the
problem is instead of putting sugar in
that coffee put a little Prozac in it
David I just want the truth this is the
truth I would be better off as a brain
surgeon than you run in this restaurant
after Chef Ramsay was served raw and
tasteless Burgers
Jan and Chef David can't seem to agree
on who has control of the kitchen I
follow the recipes as I have told what
about the mushrooms and you changed the
whole recipe
wants salt on the mushrooms and it's
starting to get personal okay let's get
down to where it's supposed to be the
way you treat us the way you're
manipulated and the way I had to buy
groceries this morning where's my money
for my groceries that you owe me now
first of all my son you haven't paid me
my son was wired this morning
excuse me we don't do that David I come
in here and I work I open the place I do
what I'm supposed to and I don't get
paid where's my paycheck that's nice I
have checks written out to your wife he
has been working on uh the spirit of
getting paid
this sounds crazy where's Jenkins she's
running to get checks all of a sudden
how do you missing the point don't
concentrate on the check I said I'm
going to pay him that's all that's
important I feel I'm a little bit sort
of in a Land of loopy Loops you see how
much bullshits flying around here your
chef says that he's forced to follow
your recipes
let's see what he can come up with
do me a favor get out there now go and
get some beef pate and cook me a burger
a burger yourself both to get out there
bye guys this is my career this is what
I love to do I'm smart enough to know
that he's gonna like my burger that Jim
is a liar dude she can't tell the truth
it's crazy the whole place should be on
[ __ ] LSD man okay I need to taste
what this guy can cook yes
Jen and David do not get along that well
he's very opinionated and that's
difficult for my wife she heard how he
attacked me
[Applause]
I am standing up for you but I'm
realizing how difficult our situation is
while Chef David shops for ingredients
for his Burger Chef Ramsay decides to
visit Daniel to get his perspective on
the issues at Burger Kitchen
Hi how are you good good to see you
hanging in there hanging in there yeah
there's a nice little cozy Place yeah
how long have you been in here five
years five years yeah five years I've
lived with Wendy for three she is my
girlfriend okay Wendy nice to meet you
too what does Wendy do I go in when he's
there only at night when they're not
there she comes in well sit down let's
have a let's have a chat there was a
falling out between Wendy and my family
my dad doesn't respect her and I don't
know why take me back to the beginning
when you invested in this restaurant
unknown to you yeah how frustrating was
that Mary your dad was handling you
money it was in a trust account right
that he had access to how do we get in
this situation my dad known as wisdom in
the way he can just manipulate said you
know why don't we open a restaurant and
I said well that's a little ridiculous
you know we know nothing about it let's
not do that but how much does it take
250 000. wow I was infuriated why did
you do this you know without even my
approval and he's like I thought you'd
like it are you kidding me this
because it's your money yeah I know
what's the relationship with your father
like now how did you get on
it's not good no I mean I can feel that
when was the last time you actually made
a decision together
my dad still treats me like a child it
almost makes me want to cry he changes
the menu way too often and he doesn't
tell anyone 10 menus more over 20 over
20 different menu changes wow I I can't
get even on the books I'm not even on
the records you know I've asked in
numerous times I've asked the accountant
this is like three months ago this is
the only [ __ ] proof I have which is a
joke this was to placate me when the
restaurant first opened that was that's
a joke that's not true this is printed
out on a computer
by the way this is nothing this is not
this is toilet paper I thought it was
gonna be bad but I didn't think it was
gonna be quite that bad I just I don't
trust them anymore it's taken a while
for me to kind of like come to that
um realization you know but um
sorry
it's hard you know it's hard to watch
this happen it's hard to watch somebody
get beaten down so much like the fight
is no longer there
okay uh well that's gonna be a even
deeper Insight run it as normal tonight
yeah and just pretend I'm not there but
I'll be in and out yeah watching
everything yeah okay okay good to meet
you both thank you okay thank you again
okay thank you see you later tonight
[Music]
back at the restaurant David is
preparing Chef Ramsay's Burger let's
call this one the Redemption burger and
for the first time since he started
working at the restaurant he is using
his own recipe but this time I want to
season far away this is very important
to me that when I make this burger it's
a good burger but at least it's going to
be my burger and it's not going to be
gin and allensberger
let's start getting this thing ready
are you making them a burger too yeah
with the wagon
a lot with the way you go I'm smart
enough to listen to what Chef Ramsay
wanted he wants a nice juicy burger he
wants something with flavor not frozen
meat
medium rare brother okay get it all
ready
let's give Ramsay a hamburger man here
we go I know if you're juicy lunch don't
worry I just made a burger my
ingredients your own ingredients yes wow
so it's not on the menu no do you want
to try it some people have called me a
meat sculpture or a meat Creator a lot
of different celebrities have eaten my
food and have said it was fantastic yes
what's in there you'll see yeah that's
right I can see the blood but what's in
there it's the uh wagoon mix but I've
what I've done is I've had certain
spices and I made a cheeseburger I don't
like a man Alan you're not at me the
expert you don't know a thing about me
the only thing you know how to do is sit
on the computer in there and change
menus that's what you do
and you made this yes it's amazing
that is hideous
at least it's seasoned
this is the Burger I'm dying for David
please
presentation it looks great thank you
Chef explain please I'm using a smart
Grier with grilled tomato spring mix
with a mustard aioli and a jumbo pickle
homemade what I
had earlier this is looks night and day
wow okay
look at that bloody hell I mean that's
what I call a burger Jesus
and how does it taste
your chef temperature's perfect and the
roll is crispy yeah sure would you like
to have a little taste I'd love to
[Music]
what is that strong taste that I'm
tasting ingredients and it's smoked
right yes yeah I love it does that go
through the meat I taste something
stronger in there like a dry aged or
something beef
but I do like my neat red in it I am a
medium rare girl problem is that's not
medium rare as it should be it may be
medium but I can tell you what it's
bloody juicy that is delicious thank you
Chef yeah I'd give that nine out of ten
love that title there by the way
Redemption burger and you certainly did
that suck on this burger Jen and you too
Alan
why aren't we serving Burgers like that
because I thought the wagyu meat was
better you've got your priorities wrong
because of the word wagyu sounds
glamorous and expensive it doesn't mean
you say it's gonna deliver you the most
tastiest burger my question to you is
that if you know that your burgers are
better
than what you're cooking currently what
can you do I'm forced into making what
they like me to make right if I try to
do a change I'm persecuted for the
making a change he wants to blame me for
everything in the kitchen and I'm not
that powerful Chef Ramsay I'm a 64 year
old woman I I can't control it that's
what he's saying how am I that powerful
do you see a chef hat on me do You See
Me swirling the pins and making the
Patties or chopping the mushrooms or
putting the salt on I mean what really
frustrates me is the fact that I get
served at mediocre crap and that thing
is seasoned juicy cheese because it's a
little bit of saltiness
absolutely delicious thank you chef
Jen whatever
Jen where's she going this is ridiculous
David has proven to Chef Ramsay that
thing is seasoned beautifully absolutely
delicious he can cook a winning Burger
when he is not confined by Jen and
Allen's recipes
but the chef's success doesn't appear to
be appreciated by one of the owners Jen
Jen come on
question
thank you Jen got up from the tasting
because Jen wanted me to be the reason
that their pitiful restaurant hasn't
made it
man what's the matter what's wrong
I'm 64 years old I've been through many
many different situations my situation
is to get this restaurant
productive
it's not about some bully or some fool
is that why you just walked out because
my heart hurt what do I do is that a
false thing if I have to sit there and
smile and say that that everything is
fine I can't do that nobody just didn't
tell me what's going on that's all I'm
facing a bully who has been abusive to
me who's we need to address this but
just for you to get up and walk out it
just looks a little bit weird I need you
and I think more importantly I think
Alan does
yeah okay please okay I feel a good
energy from Chef Ramsay if I was here to
be in a positive place I felt very
comfortable in coming back okay Jen's
back founder uh yes you got a little bit
upset and she was uh I understand well
because I I know that the chef can
deliver this kind of birth please and
should have delivered it before why did
Jim just walk out the back door
that was a different issue that's
another issue
say nasty things to me let me explain
something I don't care what you said
eight to 12 chefs walk out since the day
I walked in here you want me to fail I
think that woman's a shark if you get in
the water with them you might get your
testicles a bit off the reason you
walked out the back door is because you
wanted Chef Francis
right stop stop there two seconds I want
to see the place in operation are you
running your job watching you do your
job and you run in the kitchen
finished service we'll talk after that
cheers thank you let's go
[Music]
as the staff prepares for dinner service
one other thing Alan is something he
wants to share with Chef Ramsay I'd like
to give you my book you've got your own
cookbook I wrote a book you wrote a book
yeah I wrote a book gentle Satan it was
about my father my that's what my mother
called him is that you on the cover
there that's my father that's your
father that's me did you have a bad
relationship with him yeah because 34
years ago he wanted me to stay in
Australia and be in his business and I
said dad I don't want to be in their
business plus I've met a wonderful girl
in New York I want to move that I said
if you leave Australia it'll be the end
of us forever you didn't want to be
controlled right I didn't want to be
controlled did you love him
it's hard to say it's a love-hate
relationship how can you love someone
who stabbed you so much in the back and
to think that a father would do that to
his own son is beyond shocking um it
sounds like a killing rate I'll have a
reader that's all right thank you very
much bedtime
[Music]
welcome to Burger Kitchen my name is
Alan I'm the owner thank you for coming
from the moment Chef Ramsay arrived he
has been hit with a variety of issues
it's now time for dinner service one two
three let's go let's go hungry let's go
okay all right okay good and for the
first time in a long time Daniel will be
working alongside his father and mother
all right what can I get you should I
get a Texas chili burger please sure how
do you want to cook immediately
okay
just chilling
bar do that you got your two tickets all
right so two Texas here one Texas Chili
that's it just one Alejandro Texas chili
burger medium hey what are you actually
gonna what are you doing tonight I've
been hosting Expediting serving good a
lot so is your father taking orders as
well no he's just hosting okay I don't
want him to do I've been wanting to just
stay by the register yeah and just run
bills he doesn't like listening does he
no one likes to see it that beer is
rated in the top 10 in California by the
leading beer editor excellent beer I
didn't want my dad to be host again yes
a breath problem he does have bad breath
he walks around with bad breath and I
know I know for a fact I've seen it some
of the customers when he starts talking
they lean back every beer that's just
okay come on
doesn't listen doesn't listen okay Danny
do you mind if I see you in my office
I did I'm not talking to you just for a
second all I did was greet people that's
fine I didn't do anything else I know
okay so listen I'm happy to take that
role I don't need any other fine then
greet and then don't Linger on the
tables I won't linger you're mistaken
about my your mistake Alan and Daniel
never work together
and yell the relationship was that
fragmented no it's just it's just how it
is Daniel's dad doesn't listen no matter
how hard you fight he doesn't understand
the word no he just doesn't he doesn't
listen to Danny all right so where are
we at we're okay I can't do these
tickets like this there's not enough
room for him all right it's okay it's
okay I'll help you I'll help you I'll
help you I'm waiting for a breakfast
that's what turkey meat is that
breakfast turkey yes no that's a god
boss okay
I don't need you second guessing me
Oscar I'm not going to
despite all the confusion in the kitchen
let's go guys pick it up burgers are
being sent out quickly got a breakfast
burger here but that doesn't mean the
customers are satisfied with their meals
yeah it's really mushy oh okay and his
dinner service continues
so does the pattern of unhappy customers
all right this is not medium well I'm
sorry about that oh [ __ ] medium well
that's not a medium
guys this isn't a medium well and
frequent returns to the kitchen level
52. this was not supposed to be a junior
cheeseburger I'm not going to say that
the food isn't the problem but the
entire ticket system is messed up it's
total chaos let me show you something
say it says Junior version okay that's a
junior cheeseburger with fries let's go
with it
what's really screwed up is the ticket
system
right now I'm talking about your ticket
system you have the carbons here the
order comes out you give the carbon to
the waiter they take it to the table
that's it final done simple you know I
don't know let me run it I can run it
then
you can go behind there and I'll run it
David doesn't even know what the [ __ ]
he's doing he looks like a deer in
headlights a trained monkey could take
tickets and get them out on time that's
nothing I've never seen a family so
worth it being thrown under a bus no
one's being thrown under a buster man
thank you very much you're welcome
yes
I think this place needs helps so bad
with the ticketing process it's hard for
the kitchen to really take time and
focus on every burger and make it the
best table two do they have their fries
table two there is no table too table
parking too Jesus guys
42. there's two guests
it says people right there two listen
you're [ __ ] let's say table two it
says 42. there's two peoples up table
two knocking out 42 [ __ ] guests
I'm gonna jump off this side of the Sega
knock your ass out of you know
come here right now man come here right
now
get out of here he wants to [ __ ]
fight me you want to threaten me you
want to threaten me get the [ __ ] out
right now yeah get out right now get up
right now get the [ __ ] out right now out
get up done you're done [ __ ]
it's 90 minutes into a terrible dinner
service I'm gonna jump over the side and
say and knock your ass out
you are come here right now come here
right now Chef David is targeting
another member of this dysfunctional
family you want to threaten me get the
[ __ ] out right now
[Music]
probably in the wrong but I'm not gonna
have some crackhead yell at me don't do
that right now what the [ __ ] dude it was
a miscommunication on the bike don't
I've taken so much [ __ ] from so many
people there's so many that I just
cracked I cracked what's wrong oh he's
in there screaming like a maniac I told
him to screaming at me quit acting like
can I jump over there and thump his ass
I don't mean acting like that in there
they've got too much confusion going on
you've got Danny you've got his
girlfriend you've got the mother and
you've got the father and none of them
go to the top floor the elevator don't
go there brother I'm sorry Chef did he
ask you to leave with yes he did he told
me I'm fired
[Music]
this is the most [ __ ] up place I've
ever worked at the entire family is
insane they're all crazy I don't know
what to say
David weapons and they're gonna beat me
up so I fired him
he's always this crazy always uh all
right 14.
this is too rare look at this oh come on
what is this what was this that was
supposed to be all double check the
ticket but I think it's a Somerset Shire
it's supposed to be medium rare come on
guys I'd rather keep them waiting five
minutes for something cooked beautifully
while chaos Reigns in the kitchen not
surprisingly the dining room is a
disaster as well oh my goodness there's
no customers
and they just got up and went they said
they don't want to order anything else
all they had was a root beer float so I
gave it to him on the house
when a customer gets up second time
around and walks out and leaves their
food and now it's terrible
Burger Kitchen Burger Massacre
dinner service completely falling apart
Chef David Blaine returns but he hasn't
come back to cook hey Jen you fired me
on his thousand dollar paycheck right
now California law states that you paid
me for you fire me just write my check
and I don't want this one to bounce
please all right I feel like playing
handball today with my checks David is
over here and he wants his thousand
dollar check because Danny's fired him
why did Danny find him
he was right to fire him he's saying he
wants his thousand dollar check the
other ones have bounced do we have a
thousand dollars to pay him you can't
talk to him right okay okay okay
David as you know I don't have a
thousand dollars right today but I can
pay you tomorrow I demand my check
because I won't come back here who knows
tomorrow if you're going to even be here
obviously going to be here that's
obvious and you know that you know what
when I don't know what to her and
hopefully you won't be here man I
telling you that give me my check and
I'll catch it tomorrow post it for
tomorrow fine you want me to do it honey
I'll just write a check for a thousand
dollars again take 20 bucks out and go
buy you a prescription of Prozac it's
not necessary
I need to say this please what do you
say did Danny give you back the money
for the produce why did he give you back
he gave you back 100 I also gave you
fifteen dollars well it doesn't take 15
out minus 20 feet of Prozac we don't
need to say that first of all Jen had
nothing to do with what happened Danny
did something about this in between me
and Danny at this point it's not between
me you it's between me and you and the
your juice and neither Prozac Now give
me my check
while Chef Ramsay has observed many
difficult situations over the years
tonight's dinner service might just be
the craziest he has ever seen give me my
check right now
please stop please
I'm not on anything he's the one that
needs this so-called Prozac I don't even
know what it does
how can you blame her for something that
Danny did I'm not blaming her I just I'm
just telling her she needs Prozac I'm
telling you the truth
to say that she needs Prozac or anything
like that that's below the belt and it's
disgusting and I've lost all respect for
it I'm not on Pro who cares if you're on
the [ __ ] project don't worry about
that
write the check for a thousand and you
can put the money in tomorrow for us
how the [ __ ] could he put the money no I
don't think so Randy please don't get
involved right now these people will
never respect him I'm just over again
and now I'm taking money and I'm just
[ __ ] up people
you don't have the money in this I'm
sorry Jesus Christ what
no I have to be legitimate Danny's not
giving you any more money he's already
giving you too much and I'm sorry that's
pissing me it's not your choice Alan
please don't yell at a girl I love it
Alan please don't you know I love it
please go out you're too much choice
just come out it's not Danny's choice
either all right
and she's a young lady please don't yell
in her
thank you and David for the record I'm
not on Prozac but for the record you
should be
thank you
[ __ ] meth heads what a joke honestly
no Marion what's wrong with this one
it's too well done they ordered medium
rare and it's white in the middle on a
night when 21 dishes are returned
and yet another Chef is fired are you
okay no Daniel is devastated
uh that was horrendous yeah you're right
I even got threatened to be beaten up
and all I want to do is [ __ ] oh I
just want to serve a good burger you
know I mean you're 29 years of age
you've got the well on your shoulders
for God's sake this is crazy
it all hit me like a Floodgate I just I
just started crying I couldn't take it
come here come outside come on take over
you wake up take over let's go we're
going under maybe I should just close
the doors I can't do this not this you
know
God that's
that's just a seat
[Music]